veamos si podemos factorizar
completamente la siguiente expresión
así que factorizar esto completamente
pausa el vídeo e inténtalo
muy bien vamos a trabajar juntos
primero intentemos sacar el factor común
de todos los términos
vamos a intentar encontrar el mayor
factor común posible de todos los
términos veamos todos son divisibles
entre 2 entonces 2 es un factor común
pero también todos son divisibles entre
4 4 es divisible entre 4 8 es divisible
entre 4 12 es divisible entre 4 parece
que 4 es el factor común más grande
observa no todos son divisibles entre x
entonces no puede ser factor común por
lo tanto lo que haremos es factorizar el
nos queda 4 por qué bueno si
actualizamos 4 de 4x cuadrada nos
quedaremos con x cuadrada
si factor izamos cuatro de menos 8x nos
quedaremos con menos 8 entre 4 es menos
2 entonces nos quedaremos con menos 2x
y si factor izamos cuatro de menos doce
nos quedaremos con bueno menos 12 entre
4 es menos 3 ahora hemos terminado bueno
parece que podemos factorizar un poco
más esta expresión podemos pensar en dos
números cuya suma sea menos 2 y que su
producto sea menos 3 bueno si el
producto es negativo entonces uno de
ellos debe de ser positivo y el otro
negativo por lo tanto podemos pensarlo
de esta manera a + b es igual a menos 2
y por otra parte a por b es igual a
menos 3
bueno si a es igual a menos 3 y b es
igual a 1 se cumplen ambas ecuaciones ya
que menos tres más uno es igual a menos
dos y menos tres por uno es igual a
menos tres entonces podemos escribir
todo esto como cuatro por equis más
menos 3 o podemos escribirlo como x
menos 3 por x más 1
x + 1
con esto hemos factor izado
completamente esta expresión así que
hagamos otro ejemplo ahora tendremos la
expresión menos 3 x cuadrado más 21 x
menos 30 pausa el vídeo e intenta
factorizar completamente esta expresión
bien vamos a trabajar juntos cuál es el
factor común más grande bueno todo es
divisible por 3 entonces podemos
factorizar 13
qué pasa si factor izamos un 3 bueno
esto será 3 x menos 3 x cuadrada entre 3
es menos x cuadrada 21 x entre 3 y 7 x
entonces más 7 x y por último menos 30
entre 3 es menos 10
ahora bien podemos hacerlo de esta
manera pero nos quedará un signo
negativo en el término x cuadrada lo que
confunde un poco en la factorización de
esta expresión podemos hacerlo pero
requiere mayor carga mental por lo tanto
en lugar de factorizar 3 qué tal si
factor izamos menos 3 podemos escribirlo
de esta manera si factor izamos menos 3
que obtenemos bueno si factor izamos
menos 3 de menos 3x cuadrada nos
quedaremos con x cuadrada si factor
izamos menos 3 de 21 x nos quedaremos
con bueno 21 entre menos 3 es menos
siete entonces nos quedaremos con menos
7 x y xi factor izamos menos 3 de menos
30 nos quedaremos con menos 30 entre
menos 3 es 10 positivo ahora veamos si
podemos factorizar esta expresión un
poco más existirán dos números tales que
si los sumamos obtenemos menos 7 y si
los multiplicamos obtenemos 10 bueno en
definitiva deben de tener el mismo signo
porque el producto es positivo entonces
a debe de ser igual a menos 5 y p debe
de ser igual a menos 2 por lo tanto
podemos reescribir toda esta expresión
como esto sería igual a menos 3 por x +
menos 5 que es lo mismo que x 5 por x
más menos 2 que es lo mismo que x menos
2 y ahora hemos factor izado
completamente